il est toujours difficile de garder de
bonnes relations après une rupture
londres et bruxelles l'ont prouvé une
nouvelle fois ce week end après une
passe d'armes par médias interposés en
cause le retard dans la livraison de
doses du groupe pharmaceutique suédo
britannique dans le contrat signé avec
astrazeneca
bruxelles devait recevoir 180 millions
de doses au deuxième trimestre de cette
année
résultat l'europe n'en aura que 70
millions
même constat pour le premier trimestre
ou lieu devrait avoir reçu au total
quelques 30 millions de doses ces trois
fois moins que prévu par le groupe
pharmaceutique
du coup la présidente de la commission
européenne ursula von der leyen menace
toutes les options sont sur la table
nous avons l'option d'interdire toute
exportation prévu c'est le message que
nous passons à astrazeneca respecter
votre contrat avec l'europe avant de
commencer à livrer d'autres pays
une menace rapidement commenté outre
manche
l'ong souligne la nature collaborative
de la production de vaccins impliquant
plusieurs pays et prévient l'union
européenne c'est que le reste du monde
regarde la façon dont la commission se
comporte six des contrats et des
engagements sont rompues ce serait très
dommageable pour un bloc commercial qui
se targue de respecter la loi
ce serait contre-productif cela
compromettrait non seulement les chances
de leurs citoyens d'avoir un programme
de vaccination appropriée mais aussi de
nombreux autres pays dans le monde et
nuirait à la réputation de lieu
le laboratoire suédois britannique avait
annoncé la plus grande capacité mondiale
pour son vaccin tablant sur trois
milliards de doses prévues cette année
soit près du double des chiffres
annoncés par pfizer bio ntech un volume
de production assurée par une vingtaine
de partenaires répartis dans plus de 15
pays à travers le monde pour les retards
de livraison a tracé n'est qu'à évoque
jeu si des restrictions d'exportation
pour faire simple
confronté à d'importants problèmes de
production en europe
le laboratoire voudrait faire venir des
vaccins produits hors sol européen
mais on ne le laisserait pas faire
un argument apparemment loin d'être
suffisant pour bruxelles